[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obama c'est devenu votre spécialité de
rendre fou votre papa et cette fois-ci
vous l'avez encore piéger avec la
complicité de votre femme
je vous le dis vous avait simulé une
opération bénigne pour un problème de
sinus sauf que l'opération s'est pas
passé comme prévu et viennent vous voir
à la clinique et papa castaldi bas c'est
un cogneur pour enchanter
pour mam et résilient zonage et clichy
je vais vous installer en salles
d'attentes dans la petite salle
attendent comme ça vous êtes tranquilles
house ko 5e et retrouve nu ces tests a
dit benjamin dit alors c'est un jalon le
font pour toi c'est cool pour toi c'est
pas cool pour lui bonjour vous venez
voir monsieur castaldi
ouais donc tout s'est bien passé mais
suivez moi il encore les bandages mais
vous pouvez quand même loin c'est cool
ça en tout cas l'opération s'est super
bien passé elle est géniale et voilà
niveau de paniquer
mais voilà qu'à bien là il va pouvoir
rentrer sains d'ici un peu plus et
réputé vu ou pas non mais là je claque
faut que tu te revient sentais bien j'ai
bien retourné
[Musique]
il est ou médecin le médecin vient juste
de passer il m'a dit que tout allait
bien donc c'est bon il peut rendre au
mans - les routes par l'antenne comme ça
deux ans et mon amour je fais des
centaines de coups tu me parles appelé
le médecin appelé le médecin
non je suis désolé madame je viens de
vous dire que en fait le médecin on peut
pas aller le voir je bon ok je vais j'y
vais pas m'énerver deux rondes
jean pierre méthé ou jean-pierre qu'est
ce tu fais à l'avenir il faut bien
malade est comme ça dans les installe
comme ça comment tu toi honnêtement la
maintenant devant 8 comment tu le fais
maintenant on va juste demandé aux
médecins pourquoi il est temps de vous
dire en fait que le médecin est passé
gentil la gauche non
il est connu qu'il faut commencer je
viens de vous dire que le médecin est
passé et qui a dit que tout allait bien
je me lance savoir non je ne suis pas
médecin je suis la femme répond non non
non je suis en famille que je connais
mon voile un peu sévère vous êtes
reconnu que faut commencer on ne va pas
commencer à les connecter à d'autres
mauvais temps a laissé pas mal mais
merci tout de suite
merci beaucoup des comptes gérés touche
par touche ça ne touche pas et c'est pas
de scandale mais on vous connaît ainsi
un autre talent et menton d'époque
d'arrivée 30 et on va tuer le complément
à une paire de couilles qui a été
greffée au menton ne soit pas seulement
moi ton miroir je suis dit c'est bon tu
l'as vu une fois c'est bon en même temps
l'amour tu sais quoi bon aller tout va
bien que pitbull maison moi je pense que
tu as fait les sinus et je pense que tu
t'étais un peu plein et que tu t'étais
soit le botox soit le petit livre que tu
voulais de fer à monsieur bonjour
monsieur le journal qui sait ni
changement ils sont là bas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais je voudrais juste
comprendre pourquoi mon mari nick fry au
fait mais c'est tout à fait normal c'est
une réaction post opérationnel tout à
fait normal ça peut durer entre 24
heures jusqu'à 72 heures ne vous
inquiétez pas tout s'est super bien
passé oui mais tant que c'est pas une
réaction là illégaux fait écouter savez
maintenant
fais ce métier là et que vous êtes quand
même pas me dire comment elle va faire
l'opération j'en fais une dizaine par
jour
les chercher outre jean-pierre mais est
ce qu'on n'a pas le droit
jean pierre valade est comme ça quand je
mets toi bien me dis que messi ne l'est
à tout ça est le médecin quand même fait
des céline est ce que tu vas à pléthore
de ses hôtesses le sien des services m
j'ai fait du sinus je comprends rien
histoire je comprends rien est-ce qu'il
est malade que je lise permettez que je
lis docteur était devenu le chef venir
ne poussez pas vous dire les uns et les
autres
gentiment ne poussez pas vous ni les uns
ni les autres
ok mais tu avais pas avoir du lourd
messieurs ce sont des intermèdes
confidentielles vous n'avez pas de
revenir à se calmer jean pierre giran
des mutuelles santé si gentil si bon si
ça fait huit ans de travail c'est normal
je l'avais montée laquelle jean louis
d'or je me suis pas laissée seule ici
les chercheurs
mais s'il faut qu'on l'ait pas vous
allez chercher un responsable et vous
revenez pas ils vont pendant la ridicule
voyez le chef de clinique et ne revenez
pas sans lui ok tout chez lui six dans
la tête quand même avec l argent du
temps avec toi donc pas besoin de vos
chats on a peur la faim de me croire là
elle porte les béninois tox alors que
c'est mal when you to je pense qu'il a
fait là bas
non juste une méprise en fait docteur
tran a fait une petite inversion de quoi
avec un temps de patienter et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est un cauchemar oui avec
bonjour docteur ce que c'est moi je vous
cherchez depuis tout à l'heure je
commande à je viens pour du botox
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est chose mais clark the tiger genou
baghdadi vous remercier je te vois c'est
terminé maintenant des 200 alors ça
c'est terminé on va trouver votre
marraine plus jamais pourquoi rochelle
benjamin castaldi est énorme
j'opère castany o castany formidable
jean pierre pierre stahl dit non mais
non mais est ce que vous voulez qu'on va
voir les petites crises de colère des
chauffeurs
on est passé quand même à ça du drame
non c'est vrai oui il voulait vraiment
on était moins bon ménage
je vais débuter la gaga cadors adam cole
a la bonne idée d'aller regarder regarde
mes choix et je les aime pas de papa je
n'ai pas joué mais je crois qu'ils ont
pu assister maintenant sourire pas fois
plus assister sur friendfeed
[Musique]